hi i'd like to announce my new book
beyond order 12 more rules for life
which i've been working on diligently
for the past three years
as of today the book is available for
pre-order in the u.s
the uk and canada i've linked to some
major retailers
including international links for amazon
in the video's description
below i've also included a link to the
beyond order page on my website
jordanbpeterson.com where links to book
retailers in different countries
will be posted as they become available
beyond order will also be published as
an ebook and as an audio book which i
have nearly finished recording
all formats will be released on tuesday
march 2nd
2021
i want to provide you with a sense of
the book in addition to announcing its
existence so i thought i would read you
a section from the overture
the introduction which describes the
book's contents in some detail
beyond order 12 more rules for life
why beyond order it is simple in some
regard
order is explored territory we are in
order when the actions we deem
appropriate produce the results we aim
at
we regard such outcomes positively
indicating as they do
first that we have moved closer to what
we desire and second
that our theory about how the world
works remains acceptably accurate
nonetheless all states of order no
matter how secure and comfortable
have their flaws our knowledge of how to
act in the world remains eternally
incomplete
partly because of our profound ignorance
of the vast unknown
partly because of our willful blindness
and partly because the world continues
in its entropic manner to transform
itself unexpectedly
furthermore the order we strive to
impose on the world can rigidify as a
consequence of ill-advised attempts
to eradicate from consideration all that
is unknown
when such attempts go too far
totalitarianism threatens
driven by the desire to exercise full
control
where such control is not possible even
in principle
this means risking a dangerous
restriction of all the psychological and
social changes
necessary to maintain adaptation to the
ever-changing world
and so we find ourselves inescapably
faced with a need to move beyond order
into its opposite chaos
if order is where what we want makes
itself known when we act in accordance
with our hard-won wisdom
chaos is where what we do not expect or
ever remain blind to
leaps forward from the potential that
surrounds us
the fact that something has occurred
many times in the past is no guarantee
that it will continue to occur in the
same manner
there exists eternally a domain beyond
what we know and can predict
chaos is anomaly novelty
unpredictability
transformation disruption and all too
often
dissent as what we have come to take for
granted reveals itself as unreliable
sometimes it manifests itself gently
revealing its mysteries and experience
that makes us curious
compelled and interested this is
particularly likely although not
inevitable
when we approach what we do not
understand voluntarily with careful
preparation
and discipline other times the
unexpected makes itself known terribly
suddenly accidentally so we are undone
and fall apart
and can only put ourselves back together
with great difficulty
if at all neither the state of order nor
the state of chaos is preferable
intrinsically
to the other that is the wrong way to
look at it
nonetheless in my previous book 12 rules
for life
an antidote to chaos i focus more on how
the consequences of too much chaos might
be remediated
we respond to sudden and unpredictable
change by preparing
physiologically and psychologically for
the worst
and because only god himself knows what
this worst might be
we must in our ignorance prepare for all
eventualities
and the problem with that continual
preparation is that
in excess it exhausts us
but that does not imply in any manner
that chaos should be eliminated
an impossibility in any case although
what is unknown needs to be managed
carefully
as my previous book repeatedly stressed
whatever is not touched by the new
stagnates and it is certainly the case
that a life without curiosity
that instinct pushing us out into the
unknown would be a much
diminished form of existence
what is new is also what is exciting
compelling and provocative
assuming that the rate at which it is
introduced does not intolerably
undermine and destabilize our state of
being
like 12 rules for life the current
volume provides an explication of rules
drawn
from a longer list of 42 originally
published and popularized on the q
a website quora unlike my previous book
beyond order explores as its overarching
theme
how the dangers of too much security and
control might be profitably avoided
because what we understand is
insufficient as we discover when things
we are striving to control
nonetheless go wrong around us we need
to keep one foot within
order while stretching the other
tentatively into the beyond
and so we are driven to explore and find
the deepest of meanings in standing on
the frontier
secure enough to keep our fear under
control but learning
constantly learning as we face what we
have not yet made peace with or adapted
to
it is this instinctive meaning something
far deeper than mere thought
that orients us properly in life so that
we do not become overwhelmed by what is
beyond us
or equally dangerously stultified and
stunted by dated
too narrow or too pridefully paraded
systems of value and belief
what have i written about more
specifically
rule one describes the relationship
between stable
predictable social structures and
individual psychological health
and makes the case that such structures
need to be updated by creative people if
they are to retain
their vitality rule 2
analyzes a centuries-old alchemical
image relying on several stories
ancient and modern to illuminate the
nature and development of the integrated
human personality
rule 3 warns of the dangers of avoiding
the information
vital to the continued rejuvenation of
the psyche
signaled by the emergence of negative
emotions such as pain
anxiety and fear
rule 4 argues that the meaning that
sustains people through difficult times
is to be found not so much in happiness
which is fleeting
but in the voluntary adoption of mature
responsibility for the self and others
rule 5 uses a single example drawn from
my experience as a clinical psychologist
to illustrate the personal and social
necessity of attending to the dictates
of conscience
rule 6 describes the danger of
attributing the cause of complex
individual and social problems
to single variables such as sex class
or power rule 7
outlines the crucial relationship
between discipline striving in a single
direction
and forging of the individual character
capable of resilience in the face of
adversity
rule 8 focuses on the vital importance
of aesthetic experience
as a guide to what is true good and
sustaining
in the human world of experience
rule 9 makes the case that past
experiences
whose current recall remains laden with
pain and fear
can be stripped of their horror by
voluntary verbal exploration
and reconsideration
rule 10 notes the importance of explicit
negotiation
to maintenance of the good will mutual
regard and
heartfelt cooperation without which no
true romance can be sustained
rule 11 opens by describing the world of
human experience
in a manner that explains what motivates
three common but
direly dangerous patterns of
psychological response
delineates the catastrophic consequences
of falling prey to any or all of them
and lays out an alternative route
rule 12 finally makes the case that
thankfulness in the face of the
inevitable tragedies of life
should be regarded as a primary
manifestation of the admirable moral
courage
required to continue our difficult march
uphill
i hope that i am somewhat wiser in my
explication of this second set of 12
rules than i was four years ago
when i wrote about the first dozen not
least because of the informative
feedback i received in the course of my
efforts to formulate my ideas for
audiences around the world
in person on youtube and through my
podcast and blog
i hope in consequence that i have
managed to clarify some of the issues
that were perhaps
left less than optimally developed in my
previous work
as well as presenting much that is
original
finally i hope that people find this
book as helpful personally
as they seem to have found the first set
of twelve rules
it has been a source of immense
gratification that so many people have
reported drawing strength from the
thoughts and the stories
i have had the privilege of bringing
forth and sharing
that was the second half of the overture
from beyond order
12 more rules for life
once again the book in all its forms
will be published march 2nd
2021 links for pre-sale
are posted in the description below
thank you from the bottom of my heart
for your interest in
and support of my work
you